hey remember that our program does
depend on your support so that we can
continue doing what we do and one of the
best things as my chair what I think
that by the end of the show I actually
may fall off the chair the chair is
collapsing very very rapidly
um one of the things we need a new chair
and this is why membership is so
important no it's something I we did a
little bit of a
renovation a little bit of a cleanup of
the studio over the weekend and clearly
some some I believe antifa might have
sabotaged my chair we'll look into that
no in all seriousness we do what we do
and we do it free of me having 10
editors and and Executives telling me
cover this or don't cover that or
perpetuate the big lie or whatever's
been going on on Fox news we're free
from all of that because our primary
source of funding is people from the
audience as much as I love Jill from
North Dakota and Bob from Tennessee and
all of this none of them are going to
write to me and convince me to do a
story differently or whatever the case
may be right and and this is the sort of
point of spreading our support across as
many people as possible we remain in
control not some big Corporation or
executive and to that end
you can sign up at joinpakman.com it's
really cheap it's really simple we do an
extra show every day for our members and
you can use the coupon code 24 starts
now to get yourself a discount off of
the cost of membership Glenn Younkin did
a very very stupid thing he agreed to do
a town hall on CNN and it went so bad so
quickly that I can only imagine he and
his staff afterwards said why the hell
did we do that let's look at a couple of
clips and remember the context of Glenn
young can becoming governor of Virginia
was that he ran
against critical race theory he sort of
ran like an issues-free anti-woke
campaign critical race Theory wasn't
even being taught in Virginia schools
and yet it was enough for him to win so
there was very little substance in
getting him to be governor and there
remains very very little substance in
his explanations about how he's running
Virginia and why he's running Virginia
in that way so at one moment during the
event a student who identifies as a
trans man asked Glenn youngin listen uh
which bathroom should I be using in your
view in your view about all of these
issues of trans and gender and whatever
now I dare you to find an actual answer
from Glenn Younkin in this video uh
Governor youngin your transgender model
policies require that students play on
the sports teams and use the restrooms
that correspond with their sex assigned
at Birth look at me I am a transgender
man do you really think that the girls
in my high school would feel comfortable
sharing a restroom with me
yep so first of all Nico thank you for
again asking the question being here
tonight and engaging in this important
discussion
I believe First when parents are engaged
with their children then you can make
good decisions together and I Met Your
Dad and I'm glad that you're both here
together that's really really important
thank you for being here I'm aware that
your father is here okay great but like
what bathroom should Nico use
I also think that there are lots of
students involved in this decision and
what's what's most important is that we
try very hard to accommodate students
that's why I have said many many times
we just need extra bathrooms in schools
we need General neutral bathrooms and so
people can use a bathroom that they in
fact are comfortable with
I think sports are very clear and I
don't think it's controversial I don't
think that biological boy should be
playing sports with biological girls uh
there's been Decades of efforts in order
to gain opportunities for women in
sports and it's just not fair
um and I think that's pretty that's
that's non-controversial and something
that I think is is pretty well
understood now here is Nico's dad
shaking his head at this again I think
these are very difficult discussions and
I am very very glad to see you and your
dad here together right it seems the big
thing is that Nico and Nico's dad are
both there that seems to be the thing
Glenn youngin most wants to talk about
so let's talk about this okay first of
all Junkin says the priority is that
people should be comfortable well then
Nico should be using the men's room
right because it's abundantly clear that
Nico would be most comfortable in the
men's room then he goes into this thing
of well the bathroom should be gender
neutral as as a complete and total
cop-out now I don't disagree okay I I
think the gender neutral bathrooms are
great this has been a thing in Europe
for a very very long time it's fine to
do gender neutral neutral bathrooms but
Virginia has thousands of public schools
and they don't even have money for extra
pencils for teachers okay the idea that
we're going to solve this in Virginia by
converting thousands of bathrooms to
gender neutral rather than actually
dealing head-on which with with which
bathroom Nico should use is absolutely
laughable now I've said this before and
this is a real practical question I
don't know how many of you are familiar
with Blair white or Chaz Bono
um the idea that what is logical and
what would make everybody the most quote
comfortable under their view is for
Blair white who was born biologically
male to use a men's room today is wacky
just Google a picture of Blair White
on the same hand on the other hand on
the same token the idea that Chaz Bono
or Bono who was born biologically female
is a trans man should today be using a
women's room again if we want to use
their Paradigm about what's most
comfortable visually based on how people
look that's absurd
so there's really a bigger issue here
which Junkin doesn't actually want to
address and this was about how the
entire town hall went there was another
moment where
um Junkin was asked about his view about
removing books for school libraries any
similarly dissembled and talked around
the issue and didn't didn't really dig
into what's actually at issue here so my
my whole approach to this
parts with
with parents know what's in the library
and parents understand what materials
are being used in the curriculum and so
last year we were able to pass a bill in
a bipartisan basis that gave Parents
full visibility into materials in the
classroom Now understand
this this mostly already exists so even
even this is a distraction well as a
first step parents need to know what's
in the library and what's being taught
in their kids classes but what's
preventing them from doing that and I
know there are people who will say well
yeah you know it's hard to get out of
kids you have you tried talking to a 12
year old 12 year olds don't want to talk
to their parents they won't tell you
okay no that may be but there is nothing
that prevents parents from going to the
school library and looking around or
from emailing the teacher or whatever
the case may be so this entire thing we
formalize that there's going to be
transparency there basically is unless
there's a rare situation going on or
special circumstances there's
transparency already it's not actually
getting at the issue of banning books
and if those are sexually explicit
materials that aren't consistent with
family values then a parent can request
a replacement a replacement material
into their child's curriculum
see I do believe that there's moments
where we have to make decisions about
what's age appropriate and what is
appropriate and those are hard decisions
but we shouldn't run away from them we
should engage in them and these are
healthy discussions for us to have what
this of course ignores and in a way it's
similar to the issue of abortion what it
ignores is just because decisions have
to be made that may be difficult books
that are edge cases for an
eight-year-old for example or does a
pregnant woman want to get an abortion
just because they were difficult
decisions or even morally complex or
philosophically ambiguous or whatever
the idea that it's the government that
should be making those decisions is
being accepted as a foregone conclusion
by folks like Glenn youngin and others
who want to get involved in curriculum
well if the decisions have to be made on
abortion they should be made by medical
professionals as well as the impact that
individuals in particular the pregnant
woman if we're making decisions about
books then shouldn't those decisions be
made by teachers and Educators rather
than by Glenn Younkin and whoever he
parted in a partisan way deputizes but
they ignore that as a reality what books
should be in an elementary school
library should they have explicit
pictures in them or not well I don't
think there should they should be there
but it's not really Glenn youngin's area
of expertise and these are decisions
that I think we should take on as
opposed to run away from yeah the the
problem is who he wants taking it on so
all of this just Babble Babble Babble
and then one more interesting clip here
where uh Jake Tapper actually gets into
it with youngin about how history should
be taught in school exactly you ask you
about that which is kind of following up
on what Brock was asking because you're
you're executive order that ended the
teaching of CRT said that it would end
the teaching of inherently divisive uh
Concepts including CRT so other than CRT
can you give us a specific example of
what is an inherently divisive concept
well no I only ran against CRT Jake I'm
not informed about anything else that
you think should not be taught in
Virginia schools yeah the inherit the
inherently divisive concepts are taken
directly from the Civil Rights Act
and they're teaching children that
they're inherently biased or racist
because of their race or their sex or
their religion they teach that a child
is guilty for sins of the past because
of their race or their religion or their
sex they teach that a child is is
oppressed or a victim because of the
race the religion or their sacks now
remember that there's two parts to this
one even though I have my problems with
critical race Theory and other critical
theories
doesn't mean that he's accurately
representing what they teach that's
number one
um and then number two this wasn't being
taught in Virginia at all the fact that
whether what he's saying about CRT is
accurate or not it wasn't being taught
in Virginia schools and of course we've
seen this in curriculum you see critical
race Theory isn't a class that's taught
it's something that is it's a philosophy
that's Incorporated in the curriculum so
and we saw it in Fairfax County with
privilege Bingo and games like this but
we also saw it in teacher training and
professional development and recommended
books and this is how they are now
sliding around the fact that this isn't
being taught which is by saying well
it's being implicitly integrated as a
philosophy and of course there are
dozens of witnesses that have said that
is absolutely not the case and it is not
what is going on in Virginia schools so
you have to understand when you build
your campaign on nothing you end up if
you ever do a town hall confronted with
the reality that there's no there there
and you're completely unable to
substantive we actually talk about
anything and that's the way this entire
town hall went I would say check out the
entire thing but quite frankly I don't
think it's worth it but not a
particularly good performance by Glenn
Younkin and even though his name is
being tossed around as a possible
presidential Contender it's not looking
really really good
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
at home for years now I couldn't be more
happy with it I recommend it to
everybody the other day even though
she's not allowed in the big bed I put
my baby daughter on the mattress and
even she loved it Helix sleep is the
premium mattress brand offering tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences take the Helix sleep quiz it
asks you about your body type your
sleeping position do you get hot at
night do you have back pain and then
Helix will match you with the mattress
that's perfect for you most people don't
know where to begin when shopping for a
mattress including me Helix makes it
simple and less risky because you know
you're getting a mattress that fits your
needs it ships free you can try it for a
hundred nights to see if you like it and
it comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty
unlike many mattress companies all Helix
mattresses are made in the USA by a
skilled production team so you are
supporting good jobs helix sleep is
giving my audience up to twenty percent
off plus two free pillows what other
mattress company is going to give you
twenty percent off go to helixsleep.com
Pacman the link is down below